hello everyone I'm Alana that's Jake
that's young and that is Ralph and
welcome to another episode of this thing
that we do where we talk about games
every few months
good name question mark this thing that
we do three questions
it's giving uh I did a thing Twitter
Vibes which I'm not a huge fan of but
um so I wanted to catch up with you guys
to talk about just like 20 22 in terms
of Game of the Year how we feel about
game the actual Game Awards nominees but
you know broader how do we feel about
2022
um in general and I thought I would just
start with the the hot easy question of
um Jake what's your game of the year oh
Jesus
um oh boy I didn't prepare I'm not done
uh so I kind of go through a process
where I I play uh catch up on games like
right up until the tail end like I don't
put out my video until like the end of
December uh so I'm still grinding but I
just rattling off Vampire survivors
rollerdrome
probably are up there for me
I could not get into rollerdrome oh what
I know how is that possible I understand
please explain I
I just sucked at it like I'm just really
[ __ ] bad at it and I was like was
that because I was playing a keyboard
and a mouse but I tried for a good five
hours and I just [ __ ] sucked and so I
just kind of dropped off because I just
couldn't get good
yeah I even emailed PR I was like I'm so
bad
thank you for that thank you for letting
us know
we wish you well in our next title
hopefully you're better at it they sent
me a video and I was like yeah yeah I
get all that I'm just really bad at it
and I sent you a how-to because you're
like you gotta do it like this on how to
not suck these stupidness helps it
doesn't mean that I don't like it like
I'm definitely it's definitely not
something that I'm like I don't like
this game because I think it's very
stylishly cool and watching people who
are good at it play it I'm like hell
yeah but for me I just I I just couldn't
I just couldn't I don't know it just
wasn't maybe just wasn't my thing I
better played with keyboard and mouse or
controller but I didn't try control
doesn't matter oh [ __ ] a control I
reckon is the only I can't imagine
playing that game with the keyboard and
mouse I feel like within the mouse like
it might be good to whip the mouse yeah
maybe midair but I played with a
controller and I I was I was good maybe
I should get it like hardwired for those
like my brain is wired for those types
of games so I was very very about it
like I I said it then but I I feel even
more strongly now where like the if I
could make a game
it would be a hodgepodge of a lot of
that like I just love skateboarding and
combos but also guns and cool characters
and sci-fi and stuff so it's kind of
like
it's just good I guess to extrapolate
for the viewers at home who've not
played roller germ because I don't think
it is nominated for game of the probably
one of the Lesser talked about game
Stood Still from a big publisher um what
is it what do you like about it uh it is
essentially a single player Arena roller
derby killing game uh where you progress
through levels that get more and more
challenging uh and it's kind of like
Tony Hawk where it's like here's a level
here's a checklist of things to
accomplish like get the secret tape but
it's not get the secret tape or collect
the letters it's like headshots six
snipers or uh do this type of grind
while grenade launchering this enemy
like
um so it's a lot of that it's um it's
also super stylized and very like I
don't I don't even know how to describe
it it's very like Indie like cell shaded
Cool vibe
um but it's really straightforward and
you're on Rollerblades and you you hop
and grind and combo around the levels
while shooting people but the ammo
refill is tied to doing tricks so you're
constantly incentivized to do a bunch of
tricks all the time and build on them
and stuff also you don't fall you can't
fall down like they're which some people
think that just makes the game baby easy
mode but it's not the case at all if you
play the game for like five minutes
because it's really really challenging
and it lets you focus on just doing the
cool [ __ ] and trying to be accurate and
kill dudes as much as possible so it's
like a really addictive thing that
progresses and in between there's like a
little bit of story and a little bit of
World building there's not a lot I wish
there was more uh it's really just about
the gameplay and uh it's good as hell
it's really good when it's challenging
it gets pretty like White Knuckle uh but
it's just really satisfying as someone
who's always wanted and really there are
games out there that do this but like
games that are Tony Hawk with guns uh
this is this is one of the good ones
this is probably the best Tony Hawk with
guns concept game it's a little bit
doomy like modern Doom in a way I felt
like the momentum of like an arena in
Doom 2016 or Doom Eternal of you
constantly needing to move and pick
stuff up
like and to even get your ammo back
right like you're running around just
like trying to get stuff done but
obviously tying Tony Hawk that and also
uh being like okay this gun for this guy
okay this gun for that guy like swapping
back and forth and just kind of like
constantly thinking but also like some
Ace Combat as well because you had to do
it in like attack passes you couldn't
just go wherever you like you kind of
have to like line up a run and be like
okay cool I'm gonna I missed that guy
that time I'm gonna Circle back around
get some distance and then like every
major attack is like like a trench run
in Star Wars do you know what I mean and
it creates this very sort of like time
pressure thing where you have to nail
that shot in that moment or you have to
Veer off because you're like [ __ ] I miss
pull up pull up and I love that and a
lot of uh enemy management too where
like you might see a heavy that like you
like I don't have any grenades so let me
go around another pass do a couple kick
flips and then I'll come back around and
blow you up like not kick flips because
you're on Rollerblades but like feet
quick feet flips
that's what they can call this game John
Woo's pro roller skater that's a good
that is that is pretty good yeah it's
definitely a really unique game that I
was actually surprised to not see get um
more nominees across the board um did it
get dominated for anything at the game
once uh not that I not that I saw it in
Indie categories oh you're gonna go
through that's cool I think it is in
Indy no no I know it's not I'm just
saying I was going to read out the
Indies but we can come back to those
when you're ready well Ralph what's your
game of the year
uh I mean like it's like God of War and
Elden ring like yeah sure that's fine
but like I just think that's kind of not
very interesting to talk about if you
know what I mean because I feel like
clearly consistent it's pretty
consistent it's like okay some people
are going to feel God of War is better
for certain reasons Elder ring is better
for others uh I mean Eldon ring has this
kind of tolkien-esque level of
imagination and reach that it just seems
so expansive it's sort of like Beggar's
belief but then obviously God of War is
incredibly cinematic and Polished and
it's just you know this summer
blockbuster and incredible uh so both of
those are great uh I you know I think
I don't really know which one I prefer I
look I think I as I said I think I had
more fun playing through God of War and
enjoyed it more per se but then I'd look
at something like at Eldon ring and I'm
just like well you just have to
appreciate what this is and just kind of
Marvel at its construction it's not just
the the impact that it had we were
talking about that for months it was all
I want to talk about for months like
mine are also god of war and Elder ring
but I feel like I have to remove God of
War because that doesn't count for me so
I feel like
I think Elden ring is probably going to
win at the at the game oh there's no way
yeah yeah but I think that both games
are fantastic and will get awarded
across multiple websites just across the
board yeah and no question yeah yeah
lucky for us to have both in the same
year they're both great yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah Ralph do you
have any any picks for games that are
not those two
um I think vampire survivors is
legitimately topped here everyone is
always like is that a meme you're just
trolling on that one like is this no
it's actually an incredible game just so
brilliantly built it has spawned like
its own sub-genre with like hundreds of
clones it is endlessly addictive it is
just pure video game like distilled you
know uh and it might be the most video
game it is the most video game of 2022
even though it was released in 2021 I
think it was just it sneaks in on this
cutoff actually got its official now
that is that what it is yeah it got it
that's right it released in Early Access
last year so it is technically correct
to say release this year too
um but it's just like just it's just
crack and it's crazy and it's it's so
good that it's just this little is it
one person developer I actually don't
know it's a real person I think it was
one person okay right right sure uh and
so just to create that sort of
phenomenon
um was was really amazing but um yeah
I'm also with Jake on on rollerdrome I
think that's easily going to be in my
top five I think that was um fantastic
one game that I really hope gets some
some love at the end of the year is
nobody saves the world because that was
that came out in early Jan I'm not sure
if anyone remembers this one it was from
Juice Box yeah I don't know okay so the
people who made guacamole Juice Box oh
yeah uh they made something called
nobody saves the world came out in
January
um for a little match clean pump behind
it it was on Game Pass and
um absolutely fantastic title it is like
an arpg
uh crossed with Zelda essentially and oh
man it's just it was fantastic oh local
co-op love that always love that yes uh
really brilliantly constructed knew
exactly what it's doing
um and just didn't deviate from that
it's pretty short as well you can move
through it like a nice Canter
um but again that kind of like very
watertight game design where they knew
exactly
which classes they were designing how
they could be be combined in different
ways what kind of dungeons they could
design that would force you to move
between these different character
classes and whatever
um so yeah so so smartly constructed so
fun
I just saw a quote that says yeah course
on horse something it's a good laugh as
well uh so that one
that one I hope really gets um some some
love towards the end of the year because
I think of definitely one of the better
things I've played people loved
guacamole I wonder oh yeah 100 oh good
it was a great title I wonder why they
didn't um push that a little bit more I
guess it's self-published it looks like
drink books
it's funny I actually thought the same
thing at the start when it when it drops
I'm like where's the marketing behind
this what's up and I still think yeah
they they really missed an opportunity
there like I feel like they fumbled the
bags they had such a great title and I
think if they just pumped it harder it
definitely would have done much better
because it really deserves it so yeah
I love the phrase pumped it out of it
man you gotta put some marketing pump
behind it pump it up let's go well we're
talking about it now
um young how about you picks for Game of
the Year 2022 yeah I mean I'm gonna have
to be boring as well and say it is
between Alden ring and God of War for me
um Alden ring constantly kept me in a
state of awe at what I was Finding and
discovering and just when I thought I'd
seen everything there was a whole other
incredible new section of the map that I
didn't even know existed that introduced
just tons of new content and new boss
battles that I was discovering in the
post game and I was just it was just
this constant ride of awe um and God of
War on the other hand was just I mean so
it touched me it sort of emotionally uh
on so many levels and the cinematography
the storytelling the the combat and uh
it's just like like uh Skillet said it's
um the Blockbuster uh with heart and so
it's just both of these games blew me
away in different ways and I'm still
struggling to pick which one of those
two
um they're just both so top tier
um
I I
um I want to say I'm leaning slightly
more towards Alden ring just because it
it really kept me
so invested for like a hundred out like
usually I tap out after like 100 hours
but I got through like 150 hours of this
game and even at that point I felt like
I was just still in that mode of I need
us I need to see more I need to see what
this whole world has to offer
and like very few games like keep my
attention for that long but then God of
War is just such a tight package that
really has exactly what it needs and is
the just the right amount of length in
my opinion
um but I think I'm slightly leaning
towards Elden ring but outside of those
two I want to give a big shout out to
tunic that game uh really really really
impressed me um with I love the game
manual sort of exploration aspect where
they hint at things and like it's like
little scratch notes that you might not
notice at first that you go wait a
minute what's that over there and then
it opens up a whole new like aha
realization that takes you to you know
different parts of the map and opens up
the game and
um it's also really precise like the
combat in tunic is just so sharp like I
loved it I really really enjoyed it um
it definitely takes some like Souls like
Inspirations from Bad friends like Zelda
and souls kind of crossed over but they
made it cute they did yeah it's adorable
the visuals are fantastic
um the art design is just amazing law in
tunic is kind of underrated like some of
the sort of yeah the entities that you
come across are just very weird and
unique and interesting in a way that I
was like what the [ __ ] is this like
you'll come across like some sort of
like a god-like creature sometimes like
even the the uh the thing that runs the
shop
it's very I don't know there's something
about it that I was like I want to know
more about what the hell this world
building is yeah yeah everything's cool
yeah it everything it evokes just makes
you want to know more about uh just yeah
what what what whatever World building
there is it it is interesting and
fascinating and then sifu also uh has a
special place in my heart this year dude
uh the combat is just um it's one of
those once you like get into the rhythm
of it it just feels so good to like know
exactly what you're doing and you're
just you know you're just in the zone
and pulling every move precisely and
you're just kicking ass and uh it's one
of those
um combat systems where you really feel
like you earned your victories yeah
um where you really earned your um you
know your progression of getting better
and getting faster at being the levels
and
um and combat combined with the art
style and the whole aging idea and all
these things I just think it's a really
clever game with uh combat that just
keeps you hooked sifu is my game of the
year for moving Elden ring and wow yeah
oh yeah I was just obsessed with it and
you're right they're like it's so nuts
that I have footage of the first time
that I played it and how bad I was and
then the fact that I can get through
that level 10 times over Without Dying
by the end and the other levels which
get way hotter is like I don't know such
a such a credit to how addictive I found
it and just making sure that I got I
think I got through every level except
the last one which I should still go and
do without diagonal and getting to that
point and the the puzzle that it creates
is it's it's a matter of knowing the
levels knowing where the weapons are and
then picking which of the XP thinks that
you can't go for and I don't know I just
I adored it I thought it was so so so
cool combined with how cool just the the
the Kung Fu moves and all these things
look I mean it's just uh stylistically
also yeah music was really cool too like
yeah I I Adore Seafood um and I have
either of you guys played it since uh it
got updated with like more modes and
scoring and skins yeah yeah I really
want to jump back in because I think
it's only going to get better is is that
stuff cool official yeah yeah it's great
it takes just the base game and makes it
cooler there's a lot of like really fun
little side stuff but I didn't play with
any of the Skins I didn't even realize
that was the thing actually
um so that's yeah top to bottom I think
see if he [ __ ] rolls and if yeah if
it went for these two Juggernaut Games
of the generation that we have otherwise
again one that I feel like I have no
real opinion on it doesn't count uh is
I just think sifu's so so so cool just
just absolutely awesome um I love their
mods oh yes yeah all the mods are so
cool the Batman one yeah man so funny
Nino I mean I'll you name it it's all
there yeah it's so good
um so there are a couple of uh games
that we have not mentioned that are
nominated for game of here at the game
awards specifically and of course not to
suggest that the game Wards is the
Beyond Idol of Game Awards my thing is
it's just an easy way to aggregate
popular opinion really
um so playtail Requiem is nominated for
game of the year has anyone played that
yes yes how do we feel it I yeah I have
not I also haven't uh I played the first
hour but I haven't gone back to it just
yet but I love the first game so is it
an improvement from the first game I
think it I think most people will tell
you that in every aspect it's an
improvement
um I the only and I would agree with
that in Broad Strokes the only thing for
me is it becomes much bigger it's a lot
longer it's okay probably at least two
times as long maybe two and a half times
as long as the first game and I feel it
becomes a little bit unwieldy as a
result of that
um and also it becomes very kind of
Triple A and I think the first game had
this sort of intimacy to it with its
double a kind of finishings that made it
really I don't know just had like a
special quality like it you couldn't
really put your finger I don't really
think the word intimate is a good way to
describe it yeah yeah very entertained
story and yeah exactly and it this is
not that it's so much bigger it's like a
big like swashbuckling pirate Adventure
it's so much more sort of brash and I
think it didn't hit me in quite the same
way as a result of that even though as I
said all of its aspects individually are
you know are better so uh but really
great game uh I I think the Sobo are
just like crushing it this last little
while because obviously they did flight
Sim and they did play tail one and now
two like this is a serious Art Studio
that's right uh they said Ratatouille in
the past as well actually funny enough
because they used to do like licensed
Disney platforms yeah yeah they made
like rolly
exactly wow
um but yeah they're a serious Art Studio
who are on the map for good and they
just make fantastic stuff so uh yeah not
certainly not my in my top 10 list for
games of the year but just a really
brilliant title I think they they nailed
it so it's up there for me it's
definitely up there it it um I think for
me what what you know holds it back a
little bit I think the the luster is
kind of gone from the first game where
it's like you only kill a couple of
dudes and it's always kind of like
impactful here it becomes very video
gamey but uh everything else I really
like I thought the performances were
better than in the first game I thought
the music was absolutely stood out to me
and it just really freaking sold like
the ending like Just Hits and uh that is
gonna make me think about it and it's
you know it's gonna like stick with me
so it sounds like Yeah from what I've
seen people tend to pretty much
unanimously think it's a really
beautiful story
um which yeah I thought the music was
fantastic and I do think the the lead is
a really great performance as well she
crushed it the only thing that I didn't
love about the first game was some of
the stealth segments
um you got a lot more of that here hell
yeah well some of it was auto fail which
I think is generally just a thing I
don't love
um are they the same in requiem
more tools
say again sorry Jake there's there's
more tools but ultimately you're still
sitting in Grass waiting for a big man
to walk by I don't hate stealth across
the cross but it was just like this the
way that that it worked occasionally
like I felt like I was failing for
things that weren't my fault necessarily
sometimes like I love Thief I'm all
right with stealth uh but again I only
have that problem with the with the
first game so
um yeah it seems like a game that I feel
like everyone pretty much unanimously is
like a very happy with the story feels
like it's really heartfelt um and it is
nominated for Game of the Year at the
game awards so obviously a lot of people
really loved it and I just need to go
back and play it you too I guess you
know yeah the only reason I didn't play
is because I never play the first game
and I feel like this is a game that you
really need to play the first game to
play the the second one right would you
say so I think so I think you're missing
out on a lot when you're going yeah it
is possible but I just I think it's not
wise to do that yeah the first one's
about 10 hours and if you like it then
you're like cool I mean I love that I
want to do more of it but if you get
through that that 10 hours and you're
like oh I've probably had enough of this
then definitely don't put a second
because okay the second is more of that
but obviously with that bigger budget
Factor sure okay good to know I'll give
it a shot
um next up is a game that unfortunately
came out at a really bad time Horizon
forbidden West
for the second time you've got breath of
the wild and you got Elden ring which is
it's nuts because I feel like those two
games like I almost feel like Elton ring
is the sequel to breath of the wild like
the the impacts they have and the sense
of wonder that you get from those two
games is so unique and so
all-encompassing
um that it just really sucks that
Horizon came up against both of them
brutal um it's really brutal I'm gonna
make a bold claim I think that Horizon
forbidden West is one of the prettiest
games I've ever played
oh yeah it's up there yeah yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely beautiful
the environments uh the creativity of
just I mean what they've done with this
world is insane the performance captures
stuff and like the that kind of RPG
style dialogue kind of uh cinematography
the way they do it it looks so just like
natural like the way the characters
aren't just sort of standing still in
the cameras and just sort of cutting
back and forth it feels so Dynamic when
the characters are talking they're
always like doing little things with
their bodies moving around making faces
you know whatever it is
um that just gives those
um interactions a lot more life than I'm
used to with those types of like
dialogue heavy games yeah where you're
making dialogue choices and stuff yeah I
was I may have said this in another
podcast or maybe even with you guys but
like that game had NPCs that show up and
they look so incredibly good that I'm
like oh this guy's gonna be around for a
while I can't wait to see what this
guy's gonna do and then he's like all
right Halo have a good day and then you
never see him again and I'm like put
that much Graphics in that one man yeah
yeah there's Graphics in that way
and they did no I think it is a
beautiful game with a really beautiful
world
um and I like the gameplay is great it's
super fun
um it just came out in a time where I
didn't end up going back to finish it
because Eldon ring came out and I
definitely also like agree with the
criticisms that that Eloy talks a bit
too much yeah
um yeah so does kratos's companions
though to be fair so it's kind of a it's
kind of a Sony thing at this point like
they're not talking about it I don't
think I don't think that's intentional
um I think it's got to be to do with
play testing it's like people yeah the
feedback is encouraging that yeah and
God of War I think it was a a better
than it was in Horizon um especially
because it were it wasn't Ali talking to
herself but it was like the companions
sometimes the hints were a little too
blatant but I feel like the timer of
like how long you have to figure it out
I wasn't like okay yeah five seconds if
you don't figure it out you'll get the
answer it was like I I usually felt like
they gave you like a solid minute to
look around and you know find your
Solutions and then it feels like the
hints got progressively like At first
it's a little vague and then the second
hand is a little more like uh maybe try
this and the third one she's like all
right I think this is a solution so it's
like there's a progression to the
dialogue-based hint system that I think
just makes it better than Horizon but
yeah they could have dialed it back a
little more still but yeah with it oh go
ahead sorry I was gonna say the only
people that can get away with it are
like Batman and girl like Batman's
always like I'll need to cross-reference
the data with the Joker's blood sample
or like geralt being like I smell
something in the wind must be witches
like yeah they can they can nail it but
I guess it's just specifically almost
like the genre style or the character
style yeah yeah I I really do think that
it would be wonderful to have that be an
option you can toggle on and off as an
accessibility option I think that that
is a Thing Worth exploring it's like one
of the things that I really wish games
would do at this point that I don't
think anyone has done is the ability to
rewind a cutscene
I don't think I've seen anyone do that
and if you could you know sometimes I'll
get a phone call in the middle of a
cutscene or something and I'm like wait
what what put that in the game I'll try
it I'll do my best what I've done a
bunch is utilize like the switches or
ps5's capture feature so I'm like this
dialogue rewind 30 like capture the game
play 30 Seconds that's a good point I
hadn't thought you watch it yeah but
yeah it would be nice to still like have
it in the game yeah but it's like a nice
little way to like sidestep that absence
yeah I don't know it just seems like
it'll be neat um yeah I agree yeah
forbidden West I think is something that
like doesn't at all surprise me that
it's up here a lot of people really
really love it um I think it's a very
well made video game that I think that I
never clicked as hard with the Horizon
Series in general as other people did
that said like I'm so impressed with
what gorilla has done especially coming
from Killzone to making this like it's
so [ __ ] cool like kind of inspiring
like you can do whatever you want
whatever you can change my man and like
oh I can't yeah I think it's a it's a
really beautiful big game that I think
maybe like
something about the I just got burnt out
on that particular kind of open world
I'm not really sure uh but I don't blame
Horizon for it it's like maybe it has
some assassin's creedy DNA that I kind
of just bounced off of at some point
same with me yeah
which is kind of a Bubba
um the next one is stray
I'm surprised to see not that it's a bad
game but it's just like I I wasn't
expecting stray of all games to be one
of the nominees me too stray is
um the only one in well okay I mean
Xenoblade Chronicles 3 is a biggest
surprise to me however I feel like
Xenoblade Chronicle 3 is so extremely
deserved that if it weren't there I
would have been like just not enough
people played it so seeing it there I'm
super happy about stray no doubt a lot
of people played it I just think I
didn't expect it to end up being
nominated for Game of the Year probably
because of the smaller scale and and
some of its limitations I don't know how
did you all feel about stray
I mean it's nice it's really nice it's
perfectly Pleasant and great to play
through uh I I remember for a long time
actually it was actually the highest
rated game on Steam for 2022 like it
eclipsed God of War I think it still
might be like the number two game right
now after vampire survivors so this is
where we get into that like interesting
question of like well if it's really
popular and everyone really likes it
then that's it right because this is the
game awards and the most people liked
this game so therefore it gets on the
list right but then it's also like well
how much did they like it has anyone of
those people really think that this is
like yes the best game that was released
this year I I'm yet to find someone that
actually says I believe this was the
best game released in 2022 uh so yeah
look I think it's lovely I'm really glad
that it exists I'm really glad for the
developers because they obviously
crushed and had mountainous success with
it but um yeah it's just a pretty fairly
Pleasant game that you kind of roll
through and you're like cool that was
nice and then you move on to the next
thing I Game of the Year nominee just
feels a little bit awkward for that one
I
well directed it is the world is
beautiful I really liked the story
um but you're right in a way that it was
more that I think I found it extremely
Pleasant yeah that I was like I will die
on a hill for this
um like it was really sweet and I I will
defend it against the like oh it's a cat
game people like it because cats I don't
even like cats very much and I really
I'm a logic I'm not a huge fan I can't
even touch them
um so three people on this podcast
related to cats that's why we're like
should it be there
even though I have that stance of like
not being overly fond of cats frankly
being afraid of them uh I I I did like
really think it was sweet and endearing
in the way that like some of the the
gameplay or puzzle solving still like
ties into cat mechanics I thought was
very cute and sweet and yeah I I loved
the ending
um but you know it's really limited you
know the the platforming is extremely
limited it's all very linear
um I think there was some of those
combat segments where really all you're
doing is shooting something and then
running away and shooting something and
running away is like not a super
satisfying mechanic for the combat in
that game
um
so it's like a game that I would
recommend I think people should play it
and I really like it but yeah it's not
one that I'm gonna die on a hill for
ultimately
yeah yeah for sure yeah it's definitely
one that like if if somebody did tell me
it was their game of the year I'd be
like cool good for you like definitely
like it can hit with some people
um I think they did a really good job of
like capturing especially too with like
the internet like it's got this very
like cozy like it's like the Lo-Fi game
feel and I think like from the direction
the art like they totally nail it it
just didn't like hit me as hard as I was
hoping cat should have had like a gun
also but
um or at least a vacuum cleaner at least
rollerblades
yeah yeah but it was it was cool it was
fine you know
yeah yeah it's one way it's a bummer I
wish that one of us had a different
opinion on it but it's like a game
that's like it's it's it's a good game
but again I've never I'm not even the
chat I'm not sure if there's anyone in
the chat that's like actually stray is
my game with the 100 I've never heard if
you would die in my comment section in
anything no one said Strays my game of
the year so again I'm sure everyone
likes this game but it's like is it the
best game
yeah yeah is it the top six best games
yeah and then there's like vampire
survivors which doesn't get looking for
Game of the Year and that is a tragedy
right now
come on now
said replace the cat with any other
animal and you get a very okay-ish game
I don't agree with that because I do
again I think I think stray is good
Beyond cat game I really do think that
um
well okay Tam just said I would die for
stray is it is Tam here damn it she's
just saying no but then he said to be
replaced with vampires
okay good there we go
classic damn vampire survivors of all
the games uh on this list vampire
survivors is the one that I keep
consistently coming back to throughout
the whole year you know I mean like God
of War I'm done with it and I'll revisit
it in a year or two maybe Elden ring
I've been done with it for a while
vampire survivors it's I'm just back in
it every once in a while uh every week
I'm at least I'm playing at least to be
fair that is a design thing like you
can't go back through but I agree I
think the games that like this year that
I've been annoyed with myself for
wanting to play as often as I have are
mini motorways which is a whole other
thing
um vampire Survivor and power wash
simulator it's those games that I'm like
I just keep wanting to play it I would
like to do something else I just wanting
to play them the way I describe vampire
survivors before and and like a video I
made was it's like that dopamine hit you
get from loot boxes but like
concentrated into a video game and then
remove the predatory monetization stuff
just like that feeling of like
anticipation that you get from like the
all the visual effects and the sound
effects of like and you're getting all
these upgrades and like you're getting
so much like stimuli from the game and
everything going on around you and it's
just like it gets you in this like
really addictive kind of uh mood so yeah
since it's slightly less popular as
we've acknowledged do you want to
explain what it is like what kind of
game is it good luck with that man it is
uh it's almost like I don't want to say
it's a self-playing game like the only
input you need to worry about is the
analog stick that's it and then
occasionally selecting an upgrade but uh
once you select an upgrade you're just
moving around with the analogs like it's
like
an orange shooter where you like like a
yeah yeah it's a passive kind of uh
horde shooter where your goal is to for
the most part avoid enemies so that you
can
as the characters automatically shooting
its stuff as you're avoiding them you
eventually start leveling up and then
you slowly start building upgrades and
you create yeah like builds essentially
based on the different combination of
items that you acquire kind of like
Binding of Isaac if you will yeah but
like a little more sort of uh focused
and it's not as many items as that but
yeah once you find the right combination
of items that then like you know upgrade
themselves based on which other items
you have with you it's like it gets
crazy just the projectiles that you
start like outputting and eventually you
know the hordes get bigger and bigger
over time but your capabilities to get
rid of those hordes of enemies gets
better and better and it's like that
Loop of like just becoming more of like
an army killer as you progress through a
a level a Dynasty Warriors
yeah like a passive Musso if you will
where you're just moving around and
letting the game do its thing
um you're just like I don't know yeah it
sounds almost like it is hard to sell I
think it is totally and yet like once
you play it and once it clicks like
people get it and like I've seen on
social media especially like in the past
month or so I think it's game pause
yeah yeah because it came out on game
plus maybe a few weeks ago it seems like
it's that's right that's what it was
Dodge that Dodge that nasty three dollar
price tag thank you
not even me immense one thing I'll add
in terms of the the like dopamine hit
you were talking about is that the way I
can kind of describe it is like the
thrill of like if you're playing a
racing game and you just in the nick of
time squeak between two other cars yeah
what if it was just that feeling
constantly yeah endlessly you're always
like
yeah like it's it's just it's good for
that and I see people I see people in a
chat and people have brought it up uh
where there are other games of this
sub-genre that are better but my only
Counterpoint to that is that I haven't
played those but but also I mean like
this has it's not just that it has this
style of gameplay that's addictive I
also love that it is like this like
weird awkward celebration of like old
Castlevania style games from the
characters Sprites to the looks of the
environment to the abilities to the
music the music the sound effects yeah
they're so good
totally yeah I think one of the the
sorry you got a lot of no no go ahead
say one of the unsung heroes of it I
think is its Achievement System as well
like it's like it's what do you call it
uh I don't they're not achievements
they're what are they called in the game
challenge unlocked or something I don't
know yeah but um basically yeah you just
you are able to go okay cool I'm gonna
play some Vampire survivors and you can
kind of set some goals for yourself
really easily because it's got this big
list of achievements or things you need
to unlock and so yeah you'll be like I'm
gonna play with this character and I'm
gonna play for 20 minutes and I'm gonna
find this thing on this map and you're
like cool and yeah there's so many of
those that you can just always find an
excuse to go back so while it is really
mindless you can also spend a good 40 50
hours just clearing through that whole
log of things and be like cool I've I've
achieved something here you know what I
mean and I think it's one of the best
implementations of achievements that
I've seen in a game because usually I
don't give a [ __ ] about achievements but
here I actually do and I found they've
guided my desire or they prompted my
desire to reconnect with it when I
haven't played it for a few days you
know it really nailed it I think it's a
it is sort of to what Jake was saying
about the forza near misses you know
it's um I would love to talk to
Apparently one person who had started
making it uh about the design because I
I agree that it is really it is
self-motivated but it's also like that
that constant feeling of wanting to
discover the next thing or like for the
next tour to come or whatever like is
also what you're saying Ralph is like
that it's
it's basically perfect at that exact
thing yeah um which I wonder if that was
an accident or like incredible
fine-tuning
yeah I feel like nothing in this game is
accidental it's so compelling like
constantly person knows what they're
doing yeah it's really really hard to
stop playing uh yeah and yeah like
stages unlock and then you get some
really weird stages down the line that
like you know I don't know the way
everything progresses it it just keeps
you going like whoa what what's next it
feels different every time again since
Discovery it turns out we really like
that in video games yeah yeah that's
Minecraft I really took off
um yeah I mean I would definitely throw
a vampire Survivor in my my top five
Cult of the Lamb is also in my top five
okay I love that game yep yeah that's up
there for me it's an incredible game
well do you want to talk about it let's
talk about that call to the web yes
it's also like a really
um funny game and has a nice personality
a nice sense of humor but it's basically
for anyone who hasn't played it Animal
Crossing with a cult uh Resource
Management Sim but also at night you go
fight demons yeah like a roguelite
roguelite animal crossing yes but evil
yes
and uh very evil it I I think that that
might have been one of the best
performing games I played all year I did
not have a single performance issue
whatsoever at any point Didn't encounter
a single bug and it's so so stylish and
so purposeful in everything that it has
like I just
I just did you see the the comparison of
like when they started out there yeah oh
yeah really great like glow up between
those two um frames but it looked really
good at the beginning like they could
have shipped that game it still would
look pretty rad yeah but the amount of
extra work they put into those visuals
to make it really pop was this is that
one of the ones that got shared because
of the GTA League yeah yeah it was
because like everyone knows Graphics are
finished first
of course I still wonder if that guy was
trolling that we all just went hard to
tell you one
if he was good job Mike my dude that was
excellent trolling we were all like how
dare you
really though Graphics no compost it
doesn't make any sense to come lost
thank you
um yeah Cult of the Lamb I think is also
um I loved the soundtrack
um that's one of the ones of this year
that I'm listening to on Spotify
regularly it's so so good and so tonally
perfect for that game and in terms of
capturing the both Sinister and very
cute style and I can't even imagine how
hard that would have been
band that they were listening to one day
and they were like hey we were lucky did
you guys hear the story well I know the
guy who did it um
okay let me find out what his name is
an individual I maybe I'm wrong I
thought it was a story where like they
heard this music live from someone a
band or an individual River and they
were like second river boy is the name
of the all right and they were like hey
do you want to make music for our game
we really like and they're like yeah
sure let's do it and then that was it
you know just from a live gig and that's
how the soundtrack got its start you
know that's so cool yeah it's fantastic
yeah and I think it was in Adelaide I
hit Adelaide sticks out of me well he's
based in Melbourne so yeah okay
yeah I mean that sounds about right A
Team the game it goes made in Australia
was it yeah yeah really yeah it's an
Aussie game what oh yeah the team is
Australia there yeah I know that in that
little yeah that's right absolutely of
course the other from Melbourne though
in Melbourne there's actually this
little surprise they had time to make a
game in between tweeting about coffee am
I right that's an Australian joke for
you that's right
straight out of the Peril the pages The
Herald Sun that one
um so basically there's like this Little
Indie Hub in Melbourne uh it's like the
one place oh actually I think brisbane's
actually doing a bit of it now but in
Australia there's like this really great
right in the scene and a lot of the
developers are actually in this one
building in Melbourne super cool but I
think it's free I think you can
use it parts of it for free I'm not sure
no idea would that would make sense I
guess it has that kind of vibe that's
commune Vibe thing but yeah a lot of
interesting stuff coming out of those
teams and that was one of them yeah
um another Australian chat that I want
to give this year that I think would
also be probably less popular game is uh
Wayward strand
um made by an Australian team I think
it's Sydney actually
um and it's probably five six hours and
it's very there's basically an Airship
and it's uh it's effectively a hospital
for old people and your whole thing is
your mom has invited you to go to this
Airship for work experience and you go
there and you just talk to people and
the whole purpose of it is very much
like sleep no more it's a play or sort
of like a dollhouse
um okay more than like a general gaming
experience where the narrative will
every single character will continue to
move regardless of what you do and I
know that a lot of games try to do that
but it's it's very intimidating to even
think about and they actually nailed it
perfectly where you're just there you
talk to whoever you want at any given
time someone will be in their room
someone's having lunch you just go
anywhere any point in time things will
move Beyond you and uh it's about
getting to know these people why they're
there what their lives were like and um
it really resonated with me strongly
because
I think the the message which is again
not a very common one for video games is
very much about how we talk to the
elderly how often they're dismissed or
how often we don't really sit there and
just talk to our grand like I don't know
what my grandma's childhood was like
I've never asked
I don't talk to old people no and it's a
weird message to go for but it was one
that I found really sweet of like okay
when I see my grandma over Christmas I
am going to stop being annoyed by the
fact that she asks me the same questions
five minutes apart that's fine and just
start actually like engaging with her a
little bit differently
um which is again very unique premise
for a game video something that I found
really sweet and uh again they do
something that I think a lot of games
wish that they could do but it's
basically impossible in terms of scope
and I think it took them about six years
which is actually having the narrative
play out constantly at all times and you
get to choose where to go so it's like a
play but you get to choose what room
you're in and things will happen
regardless of where you are so you could
miss whole story beats you can pursue
one thing or another thing and
um yeah I just I really liked it shout
out to Australia you make good video
games I'm proud sometimes sure
um the next on the list is Xenoblade
Chronicles three did any of you play
Xena blade I wish I wish I had time
finished I started it I didn't finish it
not not because I didn't enjoy it I just
yeah it's a lot I also have it it's a
long on this game
that I think is like if you're not
bought into that franchise it's it's
intimidating which is why I'm really
really glad that it's there
um I didn't expect it to get nominated
because I was like I feel like there's
no way there's no way it's it's it's ju
that franchise is not that approachable
I don't think
um but I think this one specifically
sorry go ahead
it's approachable it's just the time is
intimidating I think as a franchise you
know there's nothing to stop you from
picking up a Xenoblade game and
immediately enjoying it
um but yeah it's that kind of like oh do
you have 120 hours free no okay probably
not for you then that's that's that kind
like Persona you know yeah um the same
sort of thing where you have to have
that be committed you know yeah yeah I
think it's um it's also I think it's the
best in the the series in my opinion I'm
sure there are some hardcore Xena blade
fans who would be mad at me for some
reason let's ex baby the internet it is
what it is
um but I I really love the updates to a
combat where you can basically like
Interlink I thought that was a really
really smart it was also it's it's a
really impressive looking game it's very
funny when you compare it to Pokemon
scarlet and violet
yeah but they but but then I played
though hmm yeah I've seen some folks say
oh man I guess the switch is just like
it can't handle this game's like no I
just think the game wasn't as it's not
optimizing well constructed or as well
optimized yeah I mean we've seen the
switch handle I mean breath of the wild
pretty bad I still have frame rate drops
I think the switch is like I'm not gonna
discount the switch from those
conversations and that yes that the
hardware makes it more challenging it's
limiting yeah but I also think that like
with game freak who make Pokemon it's
that they're making multiple games a
year it's a team of about 150 yeah and
their engines clearly just outdated
um they just don't have the time like
they're on such a regimented schedule
because you know they it has to line up
with the anime it's like it's yeah I
feel like I maybe blame Nintendo a
little bit more than yeah consensus for
that like just because they have a
treadmill that you can't stop you know I
mean you have to keep running you no
matter how you know how many times you
trip over it's just like you gotta gotta
make them all gotta make them all yeah
one time yeah yeah I mean they
definitely yeah
they have endless money they can hire
more people I'm not saying it's just you
hire more bodies but what I'm saying is
this is this is a franchise with a lot
of trajectory it's not like all of a
sudden the highest grossing franchise of
all time yeah you could have four or
five years ago identified that there was
a need for this studio to scale up it's
resource based so it could produce good
good stuff and it hasn't done that
that's my logic is that I feel like
maybe there's somebody not letting them
like it doesn't make I just think I
don't I don't think I just don't think
they need to like literally Pokemon
sword and shield The Sword and still try
yeah sword and shield was like not good
and it was still the highest selling
game of the year the this one runs like
us and it already is the highest selling
game of the year even though it's only
been out for like a week you know so I
was selling Nintendo game of the year uh
no I think it's the highest selling game
of the year like full stop like really
in certain in some territory I remember
reading a headline that's kind of like
already it's in the UK or something in
the highest selling game of the year
even though it's been out for something
like that I don't know don't quite be
honest the point is if it's not that
this week it's gonna be that next week
or the year after that is Pokemon that's
how it works like Morgan Call of Duty
uh I guess that's what the headline that
I saw FIFA and like all that yeah that's
I don't quote me like it's possible he
says yeah yeah yeah in the UK right now
says Jeff McRae I definitely saw this
headline I'm not making this [ __ ] up
right but like I said if it's not that
it's gonna be something else it's just
um yeah yeah man Pokemon is is out of
control like it is the biggest most
lucrative IP in history so we shouldn't
be surprised by that result also because
they sell two copies of their games
they're just one you know what I mean
which is a massive scam that they just
keep rolling with because they know they
can get away with it to the same person
I just don't have any like all this like
oh game freak they're so over words and
I'm like no I'm not saying that no I
know you're not I I know you're not
saying that but I see it on Twitter I'm
saying like oh please cut game free some
slack whatever else I'm like well
obviously I'm the developers sure I'd
like them I don't want them to overwork
themselves I want them to lead good
happy lives but I think it's fine if the
billions of dollars that this franchise
generates can also be directed to hiring
some more people 100 game doesn't look
like this would just be a reason they
can't it's a mystery that doesn't make
sense I I guess it could just be they
have the money what do they [ __ ] need
to do it might just be complacency I
mean yeah
it's just like they don't need to update
those games that much and they still
sell gangbusters every single year you
know capitalism it's capitalism you're
under something let's go it might be
capitalism
um yeah but it is really funny to see
Santa played screenshots next to Pokemon
screenshots and Xenoblade when I was
playing I was screaming children because
I was like damn look at that Vista oh
it's beautiful I love it um Pokemon I'm
like
oh god oh all the time yeah and it has
huge biscuits too yeah yeah yeah yeah
something about those games like I feel
like it's like part of their DNA it's
like there always has to be a really
cool field with like a big massive thing
in the background that gives you this
crazy sense of scale it's been like this
cool staple of the series that I really
like it's beautiful yeah
um so very very nice soundtrack there
again I haven't finished it either um I
don't imagine I will to be honest it's
one of those things that it's like like
you said that the time is too long but I
still like would recommend it I think
it's really good and that it deserves to
be there and I was just really happy to
see it there is it gonna win absolutely
not there's no way yeah but I think yeah
sure I give it that yeah what about
Kirby what about you you're short
changing Kirby there I did love Kirby
see there you go yeah I think most
Nintendo fans would probably say yeah
everyone loved that one I keep
forgetting Nintendo's definitely going
to win family game of the year they got
four out of the five
that's where they all get done um
Kirby Mario plus Rabbids
it's a Ubisoft game yeah yeah UBC game
technically yeah uh and then I think
Lego Star Wars was one of them as well
yes
um
yeah and Splatoon 3 okay yeah all of
those make sense yeah yeah uh Splatoon
three a lot of fun I wonder if there's a
games industry Family actually just
means Nintendo
is it on mobile or on switch in your
family
okay I guess it works
um all right so are there any other like
massive uh games that we would like to
have seen nominated for for game of the
year I mean I really liked pentiment
um but I've not played enough of it to
say I don't even know if it is it
probably missed the cutoff for voting
maybe
the review embargo was before or after
but either way it would have because the
voting was concluded before the reviews
were done so yeah I guess it must have
missed the deadline for sure sure it's
also like the recency bias of it is like
I might not feel like we're in six
months but right now have you guys
played pentiment
somewhere it's just so smart like it
just feels so smart it just it's well we
interviewed Josh Sawyer the game
director and he's so smart like
intimidatingly intelligent so you're
like no wonder you feel that way because
we were just like wow this dude knows
things about history and you are right
so there you go right you'll be be
prepared to be over awed and intimidated
by intelligence that's what's going to
happen man oh wait I look forward to it
oh you just needed something different
and it's different and I was like oh
this is just right this is what I wanted
right now yeah what do you like about it
uh pretty pretty much everything so like
I'm an art history kid so I like the
style I like the influences I like uh an
unconventional story uh in this in this
weird setting that you wouldn't expect
to see in a game but I re I really like
the educational stuff and like I'm never
about that I'm usually always like oh
boring but um it has that clever feature
of uh the text boxes or when you're
talking to people certain dialogue uh
certain words are underlined and if you
hit the select button the game will pan
out of like the panel in the book and
you'll see the whole page of the book
and in the margins it'll tell you what
they're talking about like oh they
reference the Reformation this is the
Reformation oh they ran they reference
Martin Luther this is Martin Luther like
that's really smart stuff because it's
accessible it just gives you just enough
to know what's going on and go oh okay
cool all right good and I'm back in
instant and it like in and out um but
then they also do it with character
characters uh because a lot of the
character it's like oh brother this
sister that because it's all faith-based
um so the book will pan out and it'll
just give you a person's face and it'll
be like oh okay like when you click on
you're like who's Sister Mary again and
it pans out and it's like oh okay it's
very dense like you do need no it's
dense but it does do a good job of
really keeping you with it and I also
just like the the story stuff like the
dialogue Choice choices feel pretty
meaningful pretty significant
um it still feels like it has that
obsidian DNA with the different
character paths and it affecting what
you can say in conversations and also
the importance of like what you don't
say uh and then the fact that it just
dumps on so much like it wants to tackle
art history uh how writing and art was
produced at the time the state of the
churches the socioeconomic things with
the church peasant rebellions
um being a douchebag like your character
like if you make certain choices you you
feel like you come into town and you
feel like this kind of douchebag like it
but it's all like human it's it's not
like a turn off like it's it's not very
like dense and like oh fancy Dancy
writing like it's the real ass story
where like you can feel for these
characters even though it was the 1500s
yeah and I think that's what that's what
clicked with me the most sorry I talked
so much I just really like this one
I haven't played it but I've like
watched uh some portions of it and it
really does feel like a labor of love
where like they knew this is not gonna
be the game to sell out I outsell all
games like this is a very Niche feeling
game but it's like they poured
everything they have into it just
because they love making this thing and
they love the subject surrounding it and
so I'm excited like actually just dive
in and just like spend how long does it
take to beat do you know roughly do you
know uh we have it written down I think
it was like
12 13. okay so like I think like I think
like 13 hours gotcha I think I've seen
some people do 15.
um it's a good like cozy game it's kind
of like a little storybook game yeah
yeah like play it on your steam deck and
just kind of like do a little bit of it
yeah I love like it's really chill stuff
so yeah really low-fi history was my
like least favorite subject in high
school and I think that's why like I was
a little less inclined to lean into
something so historically based but I
like it does seem to have a lot of like
it's hard it's also the way that they
teach you the history is so
um
fleshed out that it doesn't feel like a
lesson it really feels like the lore of
the world awesome you can almost forget
that it's real gosh I gotcha I know what
you mean okay yeah um yeah because it
was like a murder mystery it's like a
it's like a character it's like a people
story and and kind of like a weird
murder mystery so that history's like
adds context to everything and um yeah
that sounds awesome because yeah I think
it was the way I was taught history that
made me just like go ugh please no more
that'll do it yeah what do that yeah and
it's a period history that I didn't know
very much about
um and I yeah I could been calling
people characters even feel different
people
um I I think it's just really well
crafted really really well directed and
I believe it was only a team of 13 which
like as somebody just mentioned in chat
with pentimen and grounded both of which
I love
um hella began for obsidian
[Music]
right okay there you go crazy juggling a
bunch of stuff but like they've been on
points they're one of my favorite
Studios right now I I love them and I
think like the difference between
something like outer world's pentiment
about and grounded is so enormous
um and yeah the fact that they said that
pentiment really could only exist
because of Game Pass yeah um but I also
know that like when I spoke to Josh for
the previous Journey Gamescom he was
saying that he hoped that it would be a
game that Gamers didn't play but like
your parents could play that that
anybody could pick up and play and I
hope that that happens for it too
because well you say it is Niche it's
also like by virtue of how Niche it is
almost yeah mainstream yeah because it's
gamer Niche gamer Niche I mean for sure
yeah yeah but it has the potential to
like
um Nintendogs is not necessarily the The
Gamers game you know I mean but it's
like it reached a bunch of people who
otherwise wouldn't have played you know
you know bought a DS or whatever right
yeah what even is that my parents don't
play video games the only time I've ever
played video games together is Wii
Sports you can say anything you want
about the Wii but that's an
accomplishment yeah to get my parents to
get to play video games is insane yeah
my mom was on Wii Fit and all that got
her in tomorrow from the Olivia Newton
John commercial that's why exactly
GameStop and all the EB Games in
Australia and every [ __ ] 10 minutes
like someone's Mum would walk in and be
like I saw this coming special with
Olivia Newton John do you have that
thing I'm like yes here it is there you
go yeah you definitely served my mom
I got my OLED and uh I set it up and I
put Spider-Man PS4 on it and I just
handed it to my mom like go for a swing
and it like destroyed my mom's brain
yeah it was like it was like showing
someone from the 1200s like Transformers
on an iPad like it just completely she
was like what is this that's super cool
is she able to play it a little bit
that's definitely a cool one to give
someone for sure
um yeah so next is best game Direction
which we don't need to talk about a ton
because the nominees are very similar
but I did want to mention immortality
have any of you played that no actually
I'm not interested okay
um so people love
the games that they make like her story
which I also love
um I really couldn't get into
immortality and it's a bummer because I
had like people all over my Twitter feed
saying how much they loved it and there
was something about the way that the
actual gameplay works that I just
didn't like I tried it three separate
times
um although it's basically
like you have this film reel and you
watch a scene that is live action and
you can pause and select something in
the scene that might be like a thing of
Interest like a gloss and then you hit
the glass and that will take you to
another scene but the scenes aren't
linked the only link would be that
object so it's not it's not a story that
plays out in a linear way and what
you're trying to do in terms of gameplay
is effectively click on things and
scenes to unlock the full film
effectively
um but it all plays out of order and I
just I just didn't uh find that
I don't know compelling but I know that
I feel like I'm an outlier like you've
got tens you know and I oh you're not
the only person I've heard say that
though I mean not really yeah yeah no
I've definitely heard some people who
are even fans of sambalo's work yeah I
am a huge fan yeah I haven't played it
yet I'm really Keen to um I'm you know
because I really love what he does
um but you know I've definitely heard
some of the people say they're just
really clicked for them or that like
also that the idea is a bit played out
in the sense that the way he does
exposition and gameplay is quite similar
that kind of like out of order
storytelling where you just need to
follow the breadcrumbs you tug on
something and you're like oh that leads
to the next thing and then that leads
the next thing and then you could
actually accidentally find the end of
the game in the first like 20 minutes if
you happen to click on the wrong or the
right thing depending on how you look at
it
um but yeah so for me with immortality
though it's like his previous games
um I felt like I was solving a puzzle
and in immortality I felt like I was
randomly clicking [ __ ]
um it didn't feel like I was digging
into a mystery I felt like I was just
clicking stuff so
yeah it just didn't have the same effect
on me unfortunately someone here did
just say um yeah telling lies is another
one which is really awesome yes it's
banjo but he'll take Taco Stop banjo hi
buddy hi what's your game of the year
was it straight did you like straight
it's not straight it's definitely not
um somebody in the chat did say there's
a turning point in immortality that
changes such a big twist that changes
the game so whatever that is I didn't
get far enough to to see whatever that
is so I can't comment on that um yeah I
wish one of you had played it so that I
could have a
someone who likes it because I just I
have that problem where like a game
title will throw me off like I heard
immortality a couple times and I was
like [ __ ] [ __ ] it's probably the sick
awesome game like immortality awesome
and then I don't know what it is and I
was like dude soundtrack
yeah immortality is a uh I don't
actually know why they chose that I
imagine it justifies itself at some
point but uh it's got some like biblical
themes going on in some of the film
stuff so yeah another one that it's like
seems like a good game just was wasn't
for me it happens
um it does yeah and best Direction
though I feel like there's no way that
that doesn't deserve to be there that's
a really a really specific one
um okay moving on we have narrative so
the the big Hot Topic there is obviously
that the game's uh for narrative uh play
Terr Requiem eleven ring God of War
Ragnarok immortality and uh forbidden
West which I think all makes sense um
but yeah how do you guys feel about the
the Elden ring inclusion that's been a
it's been a hot one I think it makes
totals like a narrative you know in
video games it what I love about video
games is that narrative has so many
interesting Avenues through the
interactive nature of video games you
know you can do things in video games
that you can't do in other mediums and
it's like with album ring the gameplay
itself can be its own story but beyond
that
um so much of the story is told through
like the things you encounter through
gameplay and then you dig deeper and you
know into the item descriptions or
whatever you pay attention to dial or
you can like piece it together and there
is a story there it's just you gotta
like really interact with the game to
fully flesh it out and it's
unconventional maybe but doesn't mean
it's not narrative you know so and like
elderly when you really look at it in
its totality it there's a lot there I
mean they put a lot of thought into the
lore I feel I I think bloodborne still
you know you know my my favorite
narrative in terms of the souls me too
Souls born games yeah but Alden Rings no
you know slouch on that front just
because you have to like dig forward a
little more you know it could also feel
like even deeper than that like I don't
know where I stand on how I feel about
Dark Souls I know that I observe people
talking about Dark Souls and eldering
and being like no The Narrative death
but I don't know that I I just don't
know what my opinion is and I feel that
way sometimes I'm like maybe I don't
know um but The Narrative of Eldon ring
is also one that is uh self-created in a
mindcrafty way and that like I still
felt like there was a narrative that's
built up of me finding this castle and
being like who the [ __ ] lives here and
it's not even about reading love or item
descriptions it's about like looking at
these hallways and seeing the funnels
and when what NPCs are there just the
the picture that's built of that Journey
every step of the way I think is a
narrative in a way that's just not
traditional storytelling like again even
outside of the law I literally just mean
like exploring you build your own
narrative with these weird bosses you're
fighting kind of I mean I share stories
with friends about our experiences with
Elden ring like you know we had these
two Journeys in the same world you know
what I mean like we each have our
stories to tell about how we uh overcame
these challenges or and what order
things happen and what we discovered
along the way and uh you know things
that I discovered that helped a friend
figure out something that he didn't know
about and then when he told us about his
experience I'm like oh so that's what
that's for and then like we had this
communal kind of thing going on [ __ ]
good dude yeah yeah I love like that
again that's why I say sequel to breath
of the wild like that like have you been
here yet is such a cool thing only video
games can ever do you can't do that with
a book or a movie it's so [ __ ] cool I
think that's why like go to the craters
um I think that's why the the Eldon ring
sort of discourse on social media lasted
for that long it was people sharing just
like experiences or trying to like nudge
people in certain directions or uh just
like discovering things and putting that
out there to the world and blowing
people away and then them going in and
discovering more things and it was just
Snowball Effect of like communal
narrative you know I mean yeah that's I
think what I'm saying which is probably
like the most pretentious [ __ ] ever
is I think Discovery can be narrative
yeah in a way uh Jake where do you land
on the Elden ring narrative debate uh I
think like like for me I was able to get
a grip on this world and like the set up
of it and what was roughly going on uh
more easily than some other from
software games so like I I give it
points for that
um ultimately I do fall on the like
narrative historian game like whatever
it's whatever you want man like if you
felt a story then good like that's you
know to repeat myself from the friends
per second podcast like I like
I don't like the stakes aren't that high
I don't care like if did you get a story
out of that cool you win that's it yeah
like what you like across the board uh
Ralph how about you
um no I'm basically the same I mean
personally though I I do think yes it
has a story of course it does no one's
saying it doesn't uh but when you look
at like best narrative I think there's
there's something in drama there's
something in tension there's something
in plot twist like those are specific
narrative techniques and disciplines and
I think that they deserve to be
celebrated uh and I think you know
Elden ring obviously is magnificent in
its World building and it has this
narrative that bubbles up through that
but I think it is absent those more
obvious narrative techniques that I
think something like like uh Horizon
forbidden West or God of War Ragnarok or
Plato Requiem I don't know about
immortality can make you cry right
um
well buddy videos whole like Dark Souls
law series is called prepare to cry so
is it I don't know yeah yeah yeah so
like it has all those those sets right
but again you have to have someone
excavate that stuff and yeah while
you're playing it no but there is such a
thing as as I said a way a scene plays
out a way a story is told with its beats
and its highs and lows and its tension
and whatever that is I think narrative
as well and I think that when we talk
about best narrative I mean I would look
to something that really nails that
as well as the World building stuff
maybe I don't know but um yeah so I
think there's a huge amount to celebrate
in Elden ring I definitely think it has
a narrative for sure it's a great one
but do I look at it as like the best
Narrative of the Year personally not
because I I look for those other things
as well and it just doesn't have those
yeah yeah for me Alden ring the
discovery of the narrative just like
I don't know it just made me
feel things that other games didn't
provide for me in a way that it didn't
make me cry but there was a sense of
wonder of me chasing after the narrative
that I think was really unique
um and it's like that's something I
think again very specific to video games
and it's such a again like
non-traditional way of experiencing a
narrative in terms of how people usually
think of what a story is that
um yeah I can see the conversation going
either way but for me it's like that
that uniqueness
um given this is the game awards and
it's like nice one video games video
games video games yeah exactly yeah so
for me yeah it makes sense that it's
here I still personally I will give it
to God of War yeah without question
um
yeah yeah but um Elden ring I don't
think it like doesn't deserve a place
here or anything I get why some people
might have been like I give in it to
Elden ring two um in in their own way
but I think I'm happy to see it have a
place there because it is different from
the others and the storytelling is
different and it is still powerful I'd
be very surprised if it won
when we all saw it during the Disney
showcase everyone was like oh garbage
and now everyone's like this is sick
like what happened
I saw the Uncle Ben card where it's like
if you play this card if this card is
destroyed summon Spider-Man I'm like
[ __ ] is that real is it real
I hope that's real I think it's real
yeah a friend told me it's real so yeah
I think you're right it's amazing
um best art direction is next and that's
one again we haven't spoken about is
scorn
yeah yeah
um how did everybody feel about scorn I
think that's maybe
um a more contentious one
I deserves a spot on the list definitely
Direction 100 but in general uh I guess
Ralph if you want to go first how do you
feel about scorn
Love's gone uh understanding full well
that most people will hate scorn it's uh
I think most people hate it uh okay
Hate's a strong word but I think most
people don't like it I think certainly
from a lot of the people that I spoke to
were just like nah man I just bounced
straight off this this wasn't for me I
found this too annoying there's not
enough here they're like it's if only a
few hours long it's confusing it's level
design is bad uh
well I don't agree with that personally
I actually think it's no I actually I I
wouldn't I would push back on that
respect I would say that uh I think it's
got It's purposefully trying to be
unclear and a bit obtuse and that's in
its puzzles but also and I guess the
main ways puzzles become of juices
because of its level design it's meant
to be disorienting and I think it
achieves that if it would just have
these really obvious like three lane
levels or whatever that's an
exaggeration but if the level design was
really simple I think some of the impact
of the game would be lost interestingly
enough I look at that type which I'm
playing
uh I would say doctor which I'm playing
right now I'm not sure if you've poked
around those levels but it has a really
fascinating level design approach where
it can be quite confusing at times and
you really like which way yeah it's a
whole maze yeah totally and I think it's
you get you go do I go that way or that
I don't know and it's like there's just
lots of empty dead ends and you would
otherwise streamline those because you
want your player to go from A to B
efficiently but the fact that there are
dead ends and the fact that it is
confusing adds to it and I think scorn
achieves Corn's doing the same thing but
Dockside I actually agree because I also
think it suits the world very well my
thing with scorn
um where I would argue with that is like
I think
the problem is that some of the puzzles
you can't solve because you forgot that
a room that you went to an hour ago was
still there I mean it's never an hour
but you can literally forget that a room
is there and I don't think that's smart
level design I think that's sort of
letting the player down it's like okay
there's so many tunnels and ways to go
and if I forget that this one is here
because I just completely forgot that
that elevator was there or whatever
because it's not reminding me of that I
don't I think that that the lack of
intuition there is a letdown where it
works I do agree with you that it works
really well that you should be in this
alien ship and you should feel very
foreign and you should be like hang on
I'm getting all Topsy tubby that works
it's just the fact that sometimes you
can be like wait that thing oh my God I
[ __ ] forgot that even existed which
happened to me like four times was the
one time I had to contact you and be
like dude I'm stuck I don't know where
to go no two other times that I had the
same thing I was like I don't I don't
I've been trying for so long where the
[ __ ] am I supposed to go yeah and and to
be fair actually it's so difficult to
explain it that I actually couldn't tell
you where to go and I sent you my
gameplay footage and I'm just like
here's what I recorded yeah find where
you are and go and reverse engineer it
from yeah and then when I saw it I was
like are you serious like again I didn't
I had been walking around for 45 minutes
and was like
that's not a puzzle that's me forgetting
a [ __ ] room is there like it just I I
do think you're right and and it
deserves a credit
for a lot of it but I think that some of
those puzzles the the fact that you
can't solve a puzzle because I yeah I
think you could take the edge off some
of it without it losing its impact
overall I do agree with you there were I
encountered some of those things myself
and I'm like why the [ __ ] am I going on
so yeah I totally agree with that but I
think if you took too much of that edge
off and sanded it back too much it would
just become a little bit a lot of the
power of the game would be lost the
first one first puzzle that prologue
puzzle where you're trying to get that
dude into the thing and then I loved
that because I was like what the hell is
going on with this what is what makes or
breaks it people either just get through
that or they go no [ __ ] this yeah true
and I mean it is it is disgusting it's
it's a great shout for art Direction
because it's so specific and and just
Nails the aesthetic top to bottom I
actually have a question for you guys no
so I love that art Direction wise it it
is like heavily inspired by two artists
and it does a really good marriage of
their two Styles and kind of does its
own thing but like uh how do you guys
feel about like full picture stuff so
for me where I was let down with it was
the enemy designs and stuff and like
they are a significant point of the game
these creatures that you face off
against and I found them so Bland and
kind of uninspired compared to the the
rest of the game and the rest of the
game's art and look and everything that
it just kind of like hurt the experience
for me like picking too much or no I
think the combat in general I I really
didn't like
I think even Defenders of scorn it such
as myself are like yeah the combat sucks
yeah yeah so yeah
uh no you can avoid a lot of it but
there are definitely some enemies that
you will need to score like face and you
will need to kill to be able to progress
so and including a really annoying boss
encounter oh my God yeah it's just like
literally the the way that aiming works
I was like I don't know if I'm hitting
this thing that's true that's true
perception is so bad in that game yeah
it's really cool I think I think I agree
Jake and that I actually have trouble
even recalling most of the things I
fought in that game yeah like I said it
was only like four enemies there was a
little tiny rat thing that walked on two
legs yep and then there was like a
bigger version of that it's like a
little thing isn't there uh he hangs
from the roof yep and then there's like
a big fat fat dude who you have to shoot
with a shotgun yeah like he yeah and
that's that's it those are the four
enemy types so yeah there's none of that
yeah they could have been a bit more
creative with that I I definitely don't
disagree that yeah I think across the
board that it's a game that I think I
liked it I did like scorn um
I think it it did it it's not a horror
game and I think that's the weirdest
point of marketing is that I didn't feel
like it was horror at all but I expected
it to be and I don't know if that's not
me did you guys expect it to be horror
ah no not really okay maybe it is just
me it's it's unexpect horror I expected
like creepy I expected creepy I wasn't
necessarily simulated yeah yeah that
could just be me that I was expecting it
to be I got some horror vibes from it so
okay yeah I'm surprised actually it's
not no it's it's it's almost like a
point-and-click
um Adventure game like the way that they
used to be like like it's almost like a
modern Grim Fandango in a way yeah it's
more like creepy
mistress is a great shape yes yeah mixed
with like one of those just PS like
those like ps1-ish games that were just
like
grossake of it true yeah shadow man yeah
yeah it's I think it's it's just that uh
you don't know what the puzzles are so
figuring out how to solve the puzzles is
the puzzle and that's why I give like a
Fandango a shot where you're like I
don't know what the puzzle is I just
know what I have to get through this
door
um and I I kind of missed that era of
yeah I can't believe there was a puzzle
in [ __ ] Grim Fandango where you have
to like get a breadcrumb to be sewn up
into bits to put it somewhere so birds
will go like pop up it's yeah
divide him in here let's get him
answer for that right now the fact that
that was a thing that we all just went
through is just so nuts it's it's so
obtuse but I kind of have a lot of
fondness for like just poking around in
Worlds like that and I think scorn it
was like a really nice example of that
and yeah glad to see it got nominated
for art Direction uh stray is also there
I think those two are super super unique
obviously Alden ring god of war and
Horizon
um but the the super unique ones they're
Australian scorn
um for sure and sure sure all very
different looking games for the most
part
um this is no it's the music page almost
looks exactly the same a little bit
different we've got plateau
metalhouse singer so it's Plateau
Requiem Elden ring God of War Ragnarok
and Xenoblade all brilliant metal house
singer is the odd one out and um did you
guys play that game
only played the demo or the preview
build I should say actually not the full
game I guess the full game is the
preview build expanded um sure it's it's
[ __ ] awesome like it's just I loved
it it's so so cool uh it's it's
Doom but uh but a rhythm game musical
Doom the musical yeah kind of film the
musical yeah yeah it's it's rad very
glad to see that get nominated as well
um really really fun time like that
game's super addictive and just puts you
in such a good mood and did you play BPM
I haven't played BPM so I know everyone
says it's basically BPM and I was like
no but I haven't played it it's actually
not basically BPM there's quite a few
differences between them and I was
interested to see if you had anything
well it's also a rhythm shooter though
right it is yes but the way they handle
the the the nature of rhythm is very
different because BPM is like you are
the percussion right uh and you have the
ability to do like one eight beats and
really kind of like riff a lot and
improvise a lot in your creation of that
percussion backing versus uh
um
percussion that you have to stick to
correct yeah you just need to make sure
that you click the button in time with
the music yeah and so I really like both
games but I on about I haven't played
through all of Mill Hill singer so I
shouldn't say this but I certainly just
on the back of what I played I did
prefer BPM on balance because of it's a
bill like the way you were just feeling
like you were making that music while
you were playing was fantastic so yeah
you should play BPM how long is it
that's the question
uh best audio design is kind of a boring
one no offense to the people who work
really hard on this but a Call of Duty
Modern Warfare uh Elven ring God of War
Ragnarok Horizon forbidden West and Gran
Turismo 5. the only reason I call it
boring is that it's always going to be a
racing game and it's always going to be
Call of Duty like they're always going
to be there because they're so so so
good at what they do like the the audio
design is someone who doesn't play a lot
of cod it's just the [ __ ] they do to get
those guns to sound good is so next
level and wild
um and they just they sound amazing
sometimes they'll put like six six
separate microphones on just one gun to
make sure that they have as many audio
options as possible and they shoot a
wall and then they shoot it into a large
Hollow room they shoot into concrete
like they actually go and do all of that
it's so it's so intense and just so
awesome and
um I'm not at all surprised that they're
there either did anyone play Modern
Warfare
yes just the campaign because I'm a
weirdo I love the campaigns and
generally play them I just haven't yet I
imagine I will I have a Christmas yeah
this one focuses on the um uh kind of
like this the the slower sections of
modern warfare and they kind of like
went on more of those uh so that's
really cool especially in terms of sound
design where it's very like uh you're
just in a room and like you'll hear an
enemy rustling in the Next Room or
you'll you'll hear like a gunshot come
through a door and then you know it's
very like
you know I I get why it's totally needed
it's definitely not my favorite campaign
though but yeah so people had mixed
opinions on it from what I saw I'm still
gonna play it I just always do but you
should yeah definitely it's a movie
you're like you'll have a good time you
know yeah yeah it looks that I thought
the trails look really good but yeah I'm
just uh I don't prioritize code I guess
it's like a played around Christmas type
thing yeah with those campaigns um I
didn't play Gran Turismo 7.
why does he get the time
what were you gonna say Ralph
no I think was that like uh in March was
in March wasn't it yeah and I think I
was so destroyed by February and I was
like no no more video games for me thank
you very much go outside so yeah it
looks beautiful and uh have no doubt
sounds awesome yeah um so the next one
that I wanted to make sure that we touch
on is this ongoing Indie is what I
wanted to jump to uh because we haven't
mentioned neon white
it's the one game that is that didn't
play it Banger of a video game only
played the first like two levels and
haven't touched anymore but my partner
chain this year is disgusting I hate it
mine is really bad this year too I feel
I feel bad about it yeah well that's
good I haven't talked about signalus yet
because everyone so that was gonna be
one that I was going to mention at the
end yeah I haven't played it that's the
bad news however
everything I know of signal listen I've
seen him signalus
um I am rubbing it by not having played
it because it looks like like something
I will absolutely adore it looks yeah
like I feel like it's right up my alley
I'm really looking forward to playing it
I think it looks incredible I guess I
did play the demo sorry I'm sorry young
you go it's like a cyberpunky resident
evil-esque kind of survival
cyberpunky I would say it's more just
like sci-fi horror kind of thing yeah
okay
um but yeah everyone I've spoken to says
it's fantastic it's yeah a lot of
people's game of the year I wouldn't be
surprised if it ends up being being on
there for me and I feel bad about not
doing it but it's also like I'm almost
like that because I'm not even curious
I'm like I'm gonna love this game
yeah I'm ready for it yeah I haven't
heard of it because uh Susie kept
tweeting about it yeah
Susie appreciate you mine was uh
influenced mine was Lance McDonald Man
fight Dragon uh keeps tweeting about
signalus and that's where I was like
okay yeah this looks [ __ ] cool it
almost looks like a little bit like
Hotline Miami and
some of the appearances in a strange way
um but it like just the that's really
just the aspect ratio and the specific
pixel art style
um but I
yeah I have no doubt I'm gonna love it
uh I'm just gonna get around to playing
it unfortunately
um and yeah sad that that didn't get any
nominations but maybe it's the same as
it is for all of us
we just haven't played it it's a really
a word of mouth spreaded thing I have
not seen it advertised anymore so for
sure and I think if it had arrived
earlier more people would have been able
to get on it like neon white for example
that built kind of slowly and then all
of a sudden I was like everyone was
playing it
um signals it was it feels like if it
had a bit more time out there before the
deadline maybe we'd be talking about in
the same way so yeah yeah
um so did any anyone else Jake did you
planning on white
no I did not let us down
really I know I I got my God has guns
blind spots yeah does it have guns I
don't know it does the cards are guns
yeah pick up cods that give you
different different guns so neon white
is so cool but also not necessarily a
game that I think everyone would like
it's basically speedrunning the video
game
um it's a speed running platform uh with
guns there are cards you just throw out
and a lot of little Easter eggs and
levels and I guess the the purpose
outside of this very weird very anime
narrative that is the part that I think
some people might not like so much that
like I wasn't a huge fan of but just
sort of thought was fun
um is you try to get through these
levels as quickly as you can and at the
end you'll always get a leaderboard and
uh you know you're really just trying to
beat your friends and and sometimes like
when you start off something will take
you a really long time to finish and
then you'll see the leaderboard and be
like oh [ __ ] I clearly did something
wrong but missed something so I'm gonna
go back and try this again and that's
part of the Allure really stylish really
unique and like the the thing that neon
white needed that it has is just the
ability to instantly reload the level so
you can immediately start again if you
miss a jump or whatever like it's just a
second you just like hit reload and
you're just strike right back at the
start again a little bit Yeah but um
really fun
just fast-paced
weird game that's like this is a very
strange shout but sort of like some
Mirror's Edge kind of appeal
yeah totally yeah absolutely
parkour with with gun cards you're
telling you run on walls you'd be
running on walls yeah oh climbing on
them jumping on them yeah all that stuff
yeah okay and guns yeah it's great so
the best Andy nominees are Cult of the
Lamb which I feel like we pretty much
unanimously like
um neon white lesser play but also
awesome sifu what are my games of the
year absolutely all right tuning we also
really like and stray again as well
straight really showing up everywhere
and I feel like the the indie games are
just [ __ ] awesome this year man what
a selection
killed it and they're all very different
too none of these games are similar in
the slightest it's some of the most
unique stuff uh in gaming period totally
these they can really just think outside
the box because uh these are genuinely
just like passion projects they're not
necessarily trying to chase Trends or
whatever they're just like what do we
want to make what's like something
badass and unique and cool or
interesting that's like not out there
it's just it comes from our unique
identity as a team you know and yeah
really shows that that's part of the
thing about being in use the smaller
team and the direct division can just be
so streamlined and so like here's what
we're making and here's what it is have
it if you wanted yeah
um so before I let you guys go promise
it won't be much longer I would just
touched on a games that we haven't
spoken about at all but not necessarily
in these categories um did anyone play
bayonet three
oh not finished it a little bit I
finished it yeah um really liked it
um it's is crazy wild as you'd expect
it's one of the wildest scans I've ever
played the level of imagination per
square inch is unmatched almost
um and the only thing is I mean some of
the new additions because it's very much
about like controlling these Kaiju
things during battle or in between
battles the sort of like making the
Kaiju fight uh it was it's very
interrupted a lot and it has this
incredible combat model that you just
don't get to spend enough time with
sadly because even it's verse structure
like if I don't know if you guys played
Bayonetta or don't I cry you know you go
into a space the walls come up so many
be spawn in you kick their ass you get a
score walls come down you move on to the
next thing right I founded Bayonetta
that some encounters were like 30
seconds long you know the short end of
the spectrum most of them were long in
that obviously you know one to two
minutes but I found that I was having a
lot of fun in the practice mode because
at that point I could actually like play
the game uh for like a long span of time
and really get acquainted with the
combos and really you know what I mean
so and then I looked at something like
evil West which I just played through
and I just got to fight so much more
during evil West
and I love that you know and I just
really wish that that Bayonetta or those
of my companion I guess I'd say
specifically just spent more time with
more enemies in spaces where I just got
to fight more [ __ ] because yeah there
were they were like Platinum is usually
pretty good at that
I think it's been a bit of a complaint
in the past about being and against but
also some people like no it's fine it's
about getting the Platinum score it has
to be a small number of enemies plus
they change up the enemy composition at
the height of difficulty so the whole
structure has to retain in place but I
think that's for people who really want
to play these games a lot over and over
again I'm there just for like one
playthrough and in that one playthrough
I was Finding I did not get to engage
the combat system nearly enough because
the combat system is incredible like
it's crazy how much [ __ ] you can do is
the combos it's wild like it's
unbelievable and you just don't get
enough time to get good at it on your
first playthrough and I suspect weird
you wouldn't even on your second and
third you have to spend a lot of time in
the practice mode to really learn this
[ __ ] and I'm not sure that that's
necessarily a great facet of its design
you know but other than that it's looks
pretty average as well on the switch
sadly it's um the character models all
look great and the action is really
smooth but the world is is us it's it's
terrible like it's so bad we often use
the thing it looks like an Xbox 360 game
but the levels really do look like Xbox
360 levels like it's it's bad I saw
people say that uh it looks worse than
like Bayonetta two I actually think that
it does when I went back and looked at
um at Bayonetta 2 footage I was like um
I think this looks better I don't know
I'm not sure if that's true or not maybe
that's just who knows I'm not looking at
certain Clips but yeah I actually kind
of do agree with that damn that's rough
um yeah that's still a cool game very
cool game yeah and I saw some like some
controversies around the story but I'm
not exactly sure what they were because
I didn't want to spoil it for myself so
I haven't played it like whether people
like the ending or not seems pretty
divided from what I can tell yes very
much I won't spoil that either but yes
there's definitely some strong opinions
on that I think yeah
um another one that like is very quick
one to talk about is uh Shredder's
revenge Ninja Turtles
um I loved that I like it I think it's
basically perfect uh it's just that pure
fun yeah it's it's what it does is
perfect it is a retro feeling arcadey
Ninja Turtles game it's super fun Co-op
and plays really well and it's
ridiculous and upbeat and colorful and
has also uh to Ralph's point about
vampire survivors a very fun Achievement
System
um it's just really
just it I think it's perfect at what it
does but what it does is not necessarily
enough to like elevate it to get into
your status it's just it's just
brilliant it's so well executed it gave
me a lot of nostalgia it was like that
moment in Ratatouille when the critic
eats the the you know the Raptor
flashes back to his childhood where
you're like I remember playing these
games and having a blast with my friends
with it and it was just like it was that
I was like a kid all over again playing
that game
um highly recommended it's awesome yeah
it's so good yeah
um and then I guess that like I mean
that's that's most of the big ones but
I'm also feel like like I'm forgetting
things so I was gonna throw this like to
uh Jake are there any games we haven't
mentioned this year that you wanted to
give a shout out to
um olly olly World super tight oh yeah
cool yeah very cool very good very good
it's up for uh like the sports racing
game category uh and I just love seeing
games like that uh squeak in there it's
a very cool kind of Indie and uh it it
really Builds on if you've played the
olly olly games it's like the perfect
kind of build on that formula it's still
really nice for like good quick pick up
and goes I played a lot on Steam deck of
course uh
love it yeah very good show very good
game and also still approachable for
people who haven't played any early
games yeah it's really good uh Ralph how
about you anything we didn't mention
that you would like to mention
um
[Music]
um it's a lot of sounds you just made
uh I would say oh Monkey Island I
thought was really nice yeah I was
really glad that that came out I don't
think that's a game of the year nominee
but it was just really lovely that it
exists that the team managed to sort of
reunite or some of them at least and run
managed to put that together
um and that it has this really nice kind
of throwback Vibe while also being quite
modern you know they really understood
how to take this forward and deliver
something in 2022
um and I just had a really nice time
with it it was it was great and so I'm
just happy that exists so yeah agree on
that one yeah it's pretty much all and
power wash simulator which I think later
yes and that was just great cathartic
fun and I love that me too yeah that is
it's so weird how much I liked that game
it's [ __ ] yes it is isn't it weird
but I loved it I played it for hours uh
Yong how about you anything we didn't
mention that you want to give a shout
out to you say like Multiverse was it
like a fun little flow release you know
yeah I enjoyable crossover of these like
iconic characters and seeing Shaggy go
super Shaggy mode you know all the memes
in there it's like yeah that was fun it
was like a fun little moment seeing that
game released it's weird how
consistently we're kind of giving that
foot virtually every game this year and
what's that that we're like it's a
really fun fun thing that came out
um video games they're fun sometimes I
feel like it's like the year's almost
overshadowed by these two [ __ ]
Juggernaut video games but it actually
probably was a really good year for
video games it was just throw everything
in between
I okay that's an interesting question
was
was this a really great year that's what
I'm kind of asking
what do you mean by that if you're only
looking at like why weren't there a
bunch of amazing triple games yeah I
think I mean that there are a lot of
games that I think were better than I
necessarily expected them to be like I
feel like I was often having a good time
I didn't yeah I didn't play many games
this year that I didn't like yeah I
would agree with that like I really like
that Pokemon Legends like I really
really had a good time with that and I'm
liking Violet obviously as well but I
think Oculus there's a lot of things
about it did stand out to me much more
Beyond Violet
um that that was the thing that I was
like not sure how it would go not sure
if I would dig it and then I had a
[ __ ] wonderful time and
even doctite I think I'm liking more
than I expected to for whatever go and
simulated three Tokyo she goes why Tokyo
did come out this year yeah yeah I can't
believe that I did not like that that
one is also a little bit of a letdown
for me actually yeah yeah
I also I I really like dying light too
but as time went on and I played more
games this year it kind of like yeah
gonna fall down my list that's true I
think it starts really strong in that
game but then it really wears out its
welcome by the end Rosario Dawson shows
up it's just too long it goes for too
long it's too long I agree and the story
really breaks down at the end so um
this is more sort of I guess uh you know
TV territory but I want to say like
cyberpunk Edge Runners I really really
enjoy dude brilliant I love that show
and like it it's like so many
recognizable locations from the game
that you're like I've like I know how to
get there um yeah it just felt like such
a connective tissue to the video game
itself yeah that it just like I think it
deserves a shout out on that front
cyberpunk in general I think cdpr have
done a really good job this year
obviously it's like something that hey
you have to though because What You
released
um but it's still like seeing those
those play accounts go up and seeing
people enjoy the game for the things
that like I always enjoyed about it as
someone who didn't have a ton of
technical problems on the jump yeah I
was playing with the 3080 a month after
they came out or whatever it always
worked pretty well for me on PC so it's
been it's been very nice to see people
enjoying the things about that game that
are really good yeah the things that are
good are really good so that's been cool
too is the time for Edge Runners for
sure to bring people exercise funkies is
awesome
um yeah other than that yeah Seafood
best fighting game of the of the Year
obviously
I don't know that's what we tried to get
Jeff in here to answer for it we're
gonna be like Jeff explain again he does
not he doesn't do that he's not the one
who votes but it's it is weird it does
mean that the international professional
jury all were like sifu fighting game
yeah here's a random question
he's a random question Okay Okay so
we've like done like best game of the
year game what about like game adjacent
thing
right so like one thing as an example is
I'm listening to the hideo Kojima
podcast right now is anyone else on this
yeah
so good I love it so much today he just
like was hanging out with the director
of a top gun Maverick and he was just
literally fangirling like this director
yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah and like it's
pretty clear that the Top Gun married
guy doesn't play any Kojima games yeah
no I think he knows who he is because he
actually this guy actually directed um
commercials in the past for Gears of War
and he was talking about how he was
hanging out with Cliffy B and at some
point Kojima is like oh yes I know
Cliffy B we used to see each other he
reached out to me on Twitter saying he
wanted to uh catch up but I have not got
back to him yet anyway and then he moves
on to the next point
so but there's like so many funny
moments in this podcast that I just that
are just like that it's incredible like
he's hanging out with like the director
of Ghost in the Shell the original movie
and I've listened to the first three
episodes
I Used to Know James Cameron before he
got fat now he's just directing Avatar
movies is that how you'd want to end
your career oh my God I'd want to end my
career it's the best so do you guys have
any like any game adjacent things that
you're like hey I do like is it like a
magazine like obviously talk TV which
age runners or whatever I'm trying to
just like my thing I guess yeah I would
also probably give Edge Runners I'm
trying to think of what else there has
been that's come out this year to do
with video games that I love I mean I
love dark Kane and I only watched it
this year last year but I [ __ ] it was
incredible amazing it's just amazing
mind-blowingly well made um beautiful
um
the last did Uncharted come out this
year the Last Action scene and Uncharted
I went oh that's okay that's pretty good
I think that may have come out this year
yes that is a film I also tried the
tetris flavored G fuel I've never had G
fuel now we're talking yeah
I didn't feel good it wasn't good and
also steam deck steam deck steam deck
um incredible pretty unbelievable
actually yeah it's I again I keep being
like I can buy a third-party dog
I guess I could just I have mine right
here I just buy whatever I want and it
doesn't cost what it's so nice it's like
so weird
tomorrow I'm actually uh releasing a
video that I made entirely using the
steam deck oh yeah I've edited the did
the face cam audio everything like I
edited the I made the entire video just
using this holy [ __ ] that's great I'm
gonna tell people about how that went
yeah
um nice it's like that was something
cool that I just got to test out I I was
using I used this dock that has like
this m.2 nvme SSD slot so I was like oh
so like that actually makes this like a
viable potentially you know like a
viable PC that I could use and store a
bunch of files in and you know launch
video files and edit with that and it
was steam deck was not made for editing
obviously I would not recommend it as a
this is like a plan B like if you if
you're out of every other option um but
it's like it was possible I actually
made it um happen so wow that's very
cool
yeah the gaming console being able to do
that is kind of crazy that's nuts dude
that's that's super super cool yeah
will be alive for sure
um the only other thing that I really
wanted to mention is
um I really had a great time with Halo
infinite multiplayer
um oh cool I really really enjoyed it in
a way that a lot of people didn't I
think I don't know I like it was just
[ __ ] awesome to be back in Halo I had
Lan bodies with people here and [ __ ] it
was rad
um but was that at launch or was that
like this year you did that that was at
launch though I have still been playing
this year on and off and here's the one
thing that I will say that I think is
worth mentioning is like a thing this
year is that I haven't played the
campaign
because I was holding out full split
screen
I'm excited so so so excited and it's
like I get that that [ __ ] happens
but man like it like hit me on an
emotional level where I'm not gonna like
go yell at them or anything but I was
like [ __ ] dude like I just wanted that
so bad and I have all these memories of
you know playing through those games
Split Screen Co-op on a couch for hours
with friends and yeah yeah I was just so
bad it's weird because I I think
somebody managed to like dig through the
files and like activate what's kind of I
guess it's not the final version but
there is like a split screen Co-op thing
that's already in there that already
plays pretty well I think the country
actually did it was a digital Foundry
wow yeah well I mean no I think someone
else found it and then I think that
digital Foundry uh yeah they made a
whole video on it and they're like yeah
this works this is this is viable it
works well it wasn't like yeah that's
like why they just so suddenly decided
now we're not doing this I don't know
just like yeah man priorities I guess
they just want to put they want to make
more money from multiplayer I guess sure
um I know they just launched
um a forge not too long ago as well
which um and it's really good yeah it's
already super fun so I like Taylor a lot
and I'm only including it because I
think it came after the cutoff last year
but also did not seem to get any
nominations which I think happens when
[ __ ] comes out in December people are
like
also have we not mentioned OverWatch 2
at any point
I think we all know the answer to that
I didn't know I didn't play it
I played a little bit it's it's
OverWatch you know like I I still like
playing OverWatch but it's you know it
just feels like OverWatch I wasn't like
ah two is here really weird thing to
call it two it's really dumb it's a dumb
dumb it makes no sense um like at least
if it would have shipped with the you
know the campaign thing that they're
doing maybe it could have helped justify
it depending on how expansive that
really is but just releasing the
multiplayer on its own I'm just like
it's it's OverWatch uh someone in chat
said quick bring Lucy in yeah yeah true
good point it's busy playing OverWatch
right now probably yeah let's say this
Jeff there's played I watched together I
actually um preferred going to Evolution
so like no again I didn't play OverWatch
too but that's because it didn't appeal
to me because it just looks like more
Apple watch whereas Gundam evolution is
OverWatch with Gundams and it's sick
like I really had a good time playing it
it was really really fun
um super hard very sweaty OverWatch
Vibes for sure anime nerds absolutely
yeah you just get absolutely steamrolled
and you're Furious about it even though
it's your own fault kind of thing so
it's a game I could only play in a
certain mood otherwise I'm just pissed
off but really I didn't really like it
um yeah Goat Simulator three just came
out and also uh beers and boomerangs um
I believe they're very big so that was
today
I'm actually and then there's this year
too um analog pocket and the play date
good year for handhelds ah yeah are they
still like experimenting aren't those
like sold out because like I try to get
one but I think when I checked last time
it was just like everyone yeah I think
the availability is pretty limited still
on a lot of them but it's fun stuff if
you can get your hands on them and if
you just like like Hardware like I just
like Tech I love it just like yeah me
too being a goblin that just gathers up
all these products oh yeah then it's
it's good the industry loves you for
that please enough Goblin yeah
um but um I also just wanted to give a
nice little uh shout out to
um uh stadia of all things for sending
me refunds for games that I bought and
played through stadia without me
requesting them when I got the email
saying that I had been refunded I was
like holy [ __ ] this never happens what
the [ __ ] oh yeah they just sent me the
email saying that I had been refunded
for games that I bought and played on
stadia because I actually had a like a
stadium really well for me I don't know
if you're the same young in La it just
it I it was really hit or miss for me I
was so same not consistently but like
for the most part I was like yeah I
think later in its life cycle I came
back to a little bit I'm like okay this
definitely works better now than it did
like sort of in the launch month but um
I was still like I still wouldn't play
like I could still tell the difference
in terms of the responsiveness I think
that's my main thing well it was also
just the screen just gets real pixelated
yeah I think I was using it to play
Destiny of all things because it was so
I didn't have to download it at multiple
PCS right so I could just play Destiny
in different places without being like I
don't know 100 gigabytes or whatever
okay yeah where's my refund [ __ ] you
should have them I didn't apply it they
said that they're still rolling out like
through December like to January so
maybe maybe I'm like still yeah it's not
a lot of fun I thought it was just like
just a rad thing to do like wouldn't
sure crazy unprecedented I think it's
more about like not getting sued do you
think
I'm aware of I'm gonna guess it has
something to do with it I'm sure there's
some class action lawsuit that could get
spun up if maybe you bought a game in
the games months later yeah six months
later they're like oh we're winding up
our service and you didn't get a refund
by and then it's like well if you bought
it within eight months and you don't get
a refund but somewhere within six months
I don't know then I just said they just
said [ __ ] it we're Google just take all
the money this this didn't work out
let's just move on yeah I gotta keep the
gamers happy because we're annoying
that's also true we're pretty annoying
yeah yeah that's true yeah I mean really
like the tech undeniably cool everything
else really it they it launched
generally access and they said that it
didn't and but yeah that wasn't a
thought really suicide and the business
model really I think is what killed it
stupid just ridiculous come on now what
do you think you're doing definitely
yeah so people get a shout outs to Sonic
Frontiers and trombone Champion here oh
jumbo Champion yeah that was good it is
good that's a good time I have genuine
laughs into that recently and the intro
that's like very dark soulsy yeah oh my
God it's like a video game I freaking
love it oh Ghostbusters as well
um I haven't played that yet yeah to the
disrespect of everybody but uh I will
get that I'll play it eventually that
also seemed really fun
just so yeah with a bunch of fun [ __ ] I
don't know and uh vote for Rebellion
content creator of the Year yes yes 100
I'm doing it I'm gonna do it absolutely
yeah
um we um we still have Callisto
we have my most anticipated game of the
year I'm very excited yeah Need for
Speed unbounds which looks cool uh
Marvel's Midnight Sun yep we've got high
on life oh yeah that's next month and
we've got Crisis Core they're the last
they're the last four seasons I mean
that's a lot of big releases considering
the time left ah yeah I know that's
right usually everything's like wound up
in November but there are one of all
three or five well High On Life's a bit
um but like at least four and a half
major releases
um I did get to play Crisis Core early
um I played like 20 minutes of it um I
don't know if anyone else like got a
Hands-On thing okay yeah it's it's very
much like
a visual remake more than anything but
God the video really well one of my
favorite Final Fantasy games which I
recognize is not yeah yeah I've never
played like looks at some old footage
and it's just like it's night and day
difference um but it still feels like a
PSP game in that the design hasn't
really changed much the combat does feel
better I did sort of go back and play
like the intro just to gauge the
difference and the combat does feel
significantly better the visual is
significantly better but like the level
design feels identical and so in that
sense it feels like a game that was made
for PSP that just suddenly just has
really great graphics
um but like if fans love the original my
God they're gonna love this one is what
I think I'm yeah I can't wait and
Callisto protocol Stillman was
anticipated game of the year I'm super
excited about that you know there's a
preview podcast have you seen that of
Calista particle yeah
they've been making I think enough
content at this point about Callisto
protocol but I made the choice to stop
consuming it right well there is a
prequel podcast that's voiced by you
know brilliant of tasks sorry you mean
it's like like an audio play like an
actual on Spotify right now there is a
dramatized prequel to The Callisto
protocol and I forget her name with the
actress it's Brienne of Tarth yeah and
she is in it and I've only listened to
the first like two minutes but it sounds
pretty cool and I'm gonna listen to it
ahead of playing the game I thought you
meant that it was like them doing a
podcast talking about production I was
like I've heard it
yeah
yeah that's it that's it that's it
that's her name yeah damn that's that's
awesome uh I mean Lucifer and uh uh um
yes the Keanu Reeves uh Constantine
that's what it was
um
yeah she's she's she's great yeah but
that's that's that's really cool what a
cool idea yeah I love it I'm just super
excited to jump into it so do you like
you took a listen was it like only like
the first two minutes it's like a lot of
ambient industrial noise and like they
would you know walkie-talkie like you
gotta do this and all that sort of [ __ ]
then I had to do it something else for
sure so well but it sounds cool and I'm
as I said they're like I think there's
four episodes of 20 minutes of pop-ish
uh and you know it's just like a nice
setup for when the game drops and uh you
know that's just nice early you know
getting excited kind of stuff
yeah yeah I can't wait
um all right thank you guys for chatting
with me again today uh Jake what are you
up to where can people find you thank
you for having me uh where am I what am
I who am I uh on the social medias at
Jake baldino YouTube Jake baldino game
ranks every Friday for the news before
he buys and uh the friends for second
podcast it's fun I do a podcast every
other week with my pals yeah good time
uh Ralph how about you what are you up
to where can people find you uh uh I am
shill up I am I just reviewed evil West
it's cool uh even though most people
don't really like it very much I think
it's rad and I'm gonna do midnight Suns
playing through that at the moment it
has really cool combat but the hero
stuff backward face is a little bit
wonky and I'm gonna do a Calista
protocol when that drops as well and uh
it's kind of it really and then oh I'm
going to the game awards I'm excited I'm
gonna be in La uh and gonna see people
which is gonna be cool and then I'm
gonna take some time off man because the
last three months have been a lot I'm
gonna sleep for a few months and go
outside for walks and [ __ ]
um but uh yeah it's that plus all the
reviews plus frames per second podcast
on the channel and on podcast platforms
that's that's me uh young how about you
yeah same old same old Twitter uh at
Yong yeah or Hive eventually maybe who
knows whatever's going on there
um uh and then youtube.com yeah same old
you know news occasional reviews and uh
other types of videos uh looking forward
to that steam deck video yeah yeah on
the 23rd it'll it'll it'll come out um
and uh you can kill me and God of War so
if you hate me you can you know that's
therapeutic right there so that's nice
great job by the way yeah
um but yeah uh yeah same old symbol hit
me up in any of those uh Outlets yeah I
will leave links in the description on
YouTube to where you can find everybody
and otherwise we'll see you next time we
do this
and some months let's say goodbye thank
you oh what a nice dog bye puppy all
right bye everyone
young out
every [ __ ] time